in the fighting in the north is over
someone when she understand that dodgy I
pledged to write north find him to honor
that pledge
[Music]
you
hey everybody so you requested a Jaime's
season 8 video we have a pretty good
idea based on the way he ended season 7
where he's going to pick up in season 8
in the role that he's going to fill in
the war for the dawn like where he's
going to slot in to John and Daenerys
his army as well as what his possible
end games are there are a number of
great theories but I think a couple of
them will pay off and if you are finding
me for the first time be sure to click
that belt to enable alerts so you don't
miss any of the videos we'll be doing
bonus videos every week till season 8
gets here and when book stuff gets here
I'll address that at the end of the
video the book videos will be a little
bit different but starting with Jamie at
the end of season 7 how great with those
final scenes was Cersei there were so
many people cheering in my timeline that
were just so ready for this moment to
happen for the last couple of seasons
but they kept him with Cersei for so
long I think to keep that King's Landing
story as interesting as possible because
in the books the last time that they
have sex in the last time they're
physically together is over Joffrey's
dead body after that Jaime has had
enough of her and he takes off that's
the end of it the last that Cersei hears
from him is right after her atonement
walked during dance with dragons she's
sort of sitting there she gets word that
Jamie's been seen riding around the
Riverlands with a woman who turns out is
Brienne of Tarth who's on her mission
for Lady Stoneheart so obviously Lady
Stoneheart isn't on the TV show there's
a bunch of big changes so I'll address
that later in the video we'll stick to
show stuff for now but as Jamie said
he's keeping his promise so he's riding
north to Winterfell the reason he covers
his hand up is mostly so other people
won't recognize him as Jaime Lannister
like think about the last time he was
taken upon by brigands on the road when
he was with Brienne of Tarth that's when
he wound up losing his hand so that's
not something that he wants to happen
again and it's also sort of symbolic
like he's covering up the gold like he's
covering up the Lannister parts of
himself but I actually don't think that
he's gonna make it to Winterfell in the
first episode because there'll be so
many stark reunions happening I think
that'll be like Jon at Daenerys arriving
at Winterfell so you get the Arya Jon
reunion you get all that awkward comedy
of Daenerys meeting the family you might
even get that incest bomb reveal so I
think they'll save Jaime Lannister
arriving at Winterfell
in all those reunions for episode 2 so
there are a couple really big ones I
don't think that they'll have too many
Jaime
moments with all of the characters just
the ones that are meaningful for him so
you have Jamie and Tyrion you have to
imagine that Tyrion will just give him a
shrug like oh you finally left the witch
and Jamie will just shrug and say yeah
yeah I finally did the thing let's get
to business
so Tyrion is Daenerys as strategist
Jamie will probably become their battle
commander on the ground whether you
believe the show or not the narrative
this season is that he's actually pretty
good at leading armies on the
battlefield and Tyrion isn't somebody
that's gonna ride around to the horse at
the front of the army he'll probably
develop a plan with Jaime Jaime will be
the guy on the ground while Jon Snow and
Daenerys are in the sky on the Dragons
rewind back to this season here where
he's talking to the Lannister generals
trying to organize them as they go north
like we don't have time we all have to
get up there and search he's like what
the hell are you doing we're not going
north so I think when Jaime's riding up
by himself that's it he's not taking any
of the army with him he's not even
wearing his traditional armor meaning
very big possibility that he could be
wearing Targaryen armor when he shows up
during season eight
wouldn't that be fitting he was wearing
Targaryen Kings armor when he killed the
Mad King if he winds up killing Cersei
wearing the same type of armor it would
be so poetic but that's sort of jumping
forward a little too much Jaime arrives
at Winterfell he has the reunion with
Tyrion they sort of deal with the
matters at hand after they get through
the pleasantries you have that awesome
reunion with Brienne Gwendoline Christie
was saying a lot of funny things about
this King's Landing scene here too when
she was stuck with Cersei and Jaime she
said that that was Brienne's own
personal hell even though people want to
see them together it's all about the
army they're dead this season so they
didn't really have any scenes addressing
their chemistry but that'll still be
there but the whole thing is is I have a
very specific end game in mind for Jaime
if he does survive which I hope that he
does but he kind of narrated his ending
like when he told Brienne I want to die
in the arms of the person that I love
only now it seems like the person he
loves is going to be Brienne will circle
back around a Jaime endgame in a second
there are like two big possibilities but
then probably the best Jaime reunion at
Winterfell like we've talked about
before is bran Stark bran isn't petty
he'll be all weird with them again and
Jamie will be all awkward hey remember
that last time we were together the
last time they were in the same room
together was when he pushed him out the
window
they haven't been seen together ever
since then so a lot of you have asked
the follow-up question does Jamie know
that bran is alive because they didn't
even send a raven to Winterfell before
Brant got there so have Circe's little
birds informed her about what's going on
at Winterfell I would stand a reason
that if Cersei knows very specific
information about what's happening at
Dragonstone all of season seven in
what's happening all over the kingdom
then it's a pretty good assumption that
she knows most of what's going on at
Winterfell she probably heard about
Littlefinger dying but I do think that
they want to preserve the surprise on
Jamie's face when he sees bran again for
the first time and don't forget that
Jaime has to formally bend the knee to
Daenerys and Jon Snow so they'll
obviously have that moment and if you've
forgotten there was actually a huge
scene in the second episode where he's
talking to Jon Snow about him taking the
vows of the Nights Watch so I think it's
very prophetic in a hat tip for a very
possible ending for Jaime's character at
the end of the story so check this out
for context and you'll see just think
about all the things that have happened
since this moment here sold for the wall
Lord you have a good man have you swung
it yet
of course I have at someone I mean
strange thing first time you cut a man
realize we're nothing but sacks of meat
blood and some bone to keep it all
standing let me thank you ahead of time
guarding us all from the perils beyond
the wall wildlings and White Walkers and
whatnot
a grateful good strong men like you
protecting us we've got it the kingdom's
for 8,000 years we already have you
taken your vows then soon enough give my
regards to the Nights Watch I'm sure it
will be thrilling to serve in such an
elite force and if not it's only for
life such a great scene given the things
that have changed up to this point so
Jon Snow has protected the realms of men
he's lived up to his promise in the
White Walkers have come Jaime sounds
like he totally didn't believe it when
he was talking about all those things
like White Walkers beyond the wall that
just sounds like crazy his right hand
has now been cut off it's gold so that's
why they zoomed up on his hand back here
during the first season in the way he
talks about the Nights Watch you know
enjoy yourself it's only for life have
fun taking up this noble cause is sort
of a reference for the arc of Jaime's
character so first big end game theory
that doesn't involve him dying during
the battle with a knight King is him
becoming the new Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch think about everything that
Jaime sacrificed at the end of the
finale here he was the head of the
Lannister army one of the most powerful
people in the kingdom getting ready to
have a child with Cersei not that I
think that that child will actually be
born but he gave it all up to ride north
to sacrifice himself for a greater cause
so one of the two possible endings not
including valonqar I'm not talking about
that I'm talking about after all that
stuff is done like what is he actually
doing he becomes the new Lord Commander
of the Nights Watch so that is why I'm
really hoping that he survives the other
possible ending he does wind up dying in
Brienne's
and it's Serge aura that becomes the new
Lord Commander of the Nights Watch in a
nice mirror for his father surgery and
Jamie were both these very selfish
people at the beginning of the story who
have since come all the way back around
another trippin hand over feet to
sacrifice themselves to save the realm
from the night king but I don't think
that Circe dies on the TV show without
Jamie being in proximity or is a direct
result of something that Jamie does is a
sort of backdoor fulfillment of the
valonqar prophecy remember it has to be
the little brother so there are a lot of
theories about how the valonqar will go
down I'll do a separate video about that
but just remember the way the TV show
has gone back to season one referencing
those moments so obviously there'll be a
sort of wink at that when he has the
reunion with Jon Snow but do you think
in the way the show repeats itself
it'll be prophetic Jamie will take up
the Honorable cause as he tells Jon Snow
back here during season one of the
Nights Watch eventually now again that's
jumping way further ahead in the story
there's so much that has to happen
before then but there's only six
episodes so I'm not expecting him to get
moments with every single character at
Winterfell just the ones I mentioned
like Tyrion Brienne bran stark Jon Snow
Daenerys and then again with Cersei
before she winds up dying so just leave
all you requests for bonus videos in the
comments below there'll be a new Q&A on
Tuesday like I would normally do but
I'll post a new video tomorrow and
because there's a lot of new TV that's
starting in a little while let me know
if you want me to do Star Trek videos
Westworld hasn't quite started yet but
they've started to do interviews so I
might do a new Westworld season 2 video
soon but congratulations to the latest
HBO now giveaway winner TLM please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details click here to learn all about
the golden company Jon Snow theory and
you can click here for all my other
season 8 videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight